if to all-knowing God's descended from
the heavens and played a game of Connect
four because that's what God's probably
like to do this is how the game would
end this is almost the the perfect game
of Connect four with victory here just
one disk before the end on this
horizontal line let me explain
now I grew up calling this Connect four
but I am aware it has a bunch of other
names like these if you call it
something different maybe you want to
leave a comment and basically what
happens is two players yellow and red
take it in turns dropping discs into
this grid and the game is won when
someone makes four in a row it can be
vertical horizontal or diagonal now I
don't want to be a spoil sport but this
game has actually been solved and it is
a mathematical certainty that you will
win if you play perfectly by dropping
your opening disc or stone as these are
sometimes called into the middle column
like so victory is assured
likewise you'll always lose if you open
in the four outermost columns again this
is assuming your opponent plays
perfectly but we'll take that for
granted
and start in these columns the game will
be a draw the grid will fill up before
anyone manages four in a row
so being numberphile let's talk some
numbers the first thing I want to know
is how many different ways can you fill
a connect four grid in open play well
that took experts a while to crunch but
we now know the answer is over four
trillion there's the exact number which
I won't even try to say now that's every
possible configuration including an
empty grid of course which there is one
variation of these seven opening moves
these forty-nine possible configurations
after two moves and so on
you
so how many finishes can you have how
many terminal states as some people call
up well it turns out there are getting
towards two trillion ways to win that's
the number of boards which have four in
a row and there's the exact number you
can see it's actually a bit less than
two trillium the quickest possible win
is of course seven moves because someone
has to put in four stones and there are
728 ways to do that and also it's worth
saying there are 713 million ways to
draw well actually seven hundred and
thirteen million two hundred and ninety
eight thousand eight hundred and seventy
eight but who's counting of course the
thing I want to talk about is winning
though now as I said at the start if you
play perfectly you are guaranteed to win
by dropping your opening stone or disk
into the center column but the thing I
want to know is what does that win look
like how long does it take when
obviously that's going to depend on how
the opponent plays now we're going to
assume the opponent is also a perfect
player of course if they are a perfect
player when the report does that they
know they've already lost but let's
assume they're going to keep playing
anyway they're going to prolong the
inevitable they're going to try and last
as long as they can maybe they're hoping
the other person's catching a train and
if they last long enough the game will
be a draw so if you're a perfect player
and of course if you are a perfect
player you're going to start in the
center column you will win within forty
one moves there are a few ways to do it
but this is one of them and this is what
victory looks like when red is forced to
play here because it's the only column
left yellow wins like this before making
this video I was helped out by some of
the world's finest to connect four minds
I don't know how well I took their
advice and any mistakes in this video on
mine not theirs
but of all the cool scenarios they told
me about this was perhaps my favorite
this is a game which ends with the
winner red in this case having seven
ways to finish off their opponent they
could drop the final disc into any of
the columns to perform the coup de Gras
so big thanks to all those experts who
helped out with this video and in the
video description I'm going to put some
excellent links to their sites and all
sorts of things
scenarios statistics numbers you love it
so make sure you check them out so look
at that last beautiful that is so this
is well the super flip I perform the
super flipped form the sold state you
get this really pretty combination there